welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna get weird y'all i mean it's
gonna happen
why because we put out a prompt we put
out a tweet
that said finish this sentence for an
upcoming hashtag your biscuits
discussion
am i weird because i blank and i will
say
that this was uh this is a little inside
baseball a little
internal and i don't mean like going to
the doctor i mean
i'm going to tell you a little
background on how we arrived at this
question
the first question that we tweeted was
something like here it is right here ask
ask us a question that you'd be too
afraid to ask your friends
we might answer it on an ear biscuits
the thing that we were thinking
in that prompt was we're trying to get
to like
you guys to talk about things that you
were kind of embarrassed that you might
not know about or think about yourself
or whatever
but i think the mistake was when we said
you're friends because people said
things like
are you in love with me or stuff like
that
am i annoying and so we went back to the
drawing board
and got more specific with the am i
weird because i blank
and you delivered yeah i think we may be
doing more of those type of props but i
i you would be amazed
at the amount of discussions we have
around
putting these props out there because
you know it's kind of like fishing
you you don't know exactly what you you
we have an idea what we want to get
the right lure i want to catch a fish
gotta have the right baby i don't want
to catch a turtle
so to speak so we have to and can i back
out even a little bit further and say
just just the fact that we can issue
backing out we can say
you know what finish this sentence on
social media am
i weird because i blank and then
people respond people fill in the blank
with
things that they legitimately do
and legitimately question whether it
makes them
strange or weird
this is fascinating they are that
willing i mean it's just a reality check
we're we're at a place in our lives
where we can tweet something like that
and people will respond
there's plenty of plenty of people who
could anybody can get a twitter account
right
are you just talking about the function
of having followers yes
anybody anybody can i'm thankful for
following my weird
finish this sentence am i weird because
i blank and then nobody will respond
well i think what maybe
three of them sometimes i see people
with
one to two followers like put out a
twitter poll
and i'm like uh i mean
we're nothing against having one or two
followers but if you've got one or two
followers your poll results
are going to
yeah not indicative of much other than
one or two followers
you know what it's it's nice to be in a
place where we can ask
people questions that prompt them to to
put themselves in compromised positions
and not only do we get a lot of
responses but we get a lot of strange
responses that are worth talking about
while mentioning their username because
using your phishing analogy we were
trying to
bait you into saying something or
admitting it's
something embarrassing about yourself
and it took two tries to get there
you know sometimes boy did we get there
when you go out to the lake
you know i i told you that i made the
mistake of watching
approximately 12 minutes of professional
uh fishing
recently uh that's all happened because
i was like oh i get like every once in a
while
espn will have professional fishing on
and i most of my television that i
consume
that's not streaming which most of it is
streaming but if i'm not going to stream
usually it's going to be fishing it's to
watch a sporting event and i use the
youtube tv
not a sponsor youtube tv app um
and i uh piqued your interest there was
nothing on
sports that i wanted to watch but there
was bass fishing and so i was like
hmm let me check in with bass fishing
why not right
i think everybody it's worth a shot
especially everybody from north carolina
needs to check in with
bass fishing at least once a decade
i checked in and i saw the most exciting
part
apparently of this tournament was these
two guys
who were trying to win different boats
different locations
different boats and then they were not
catching
anything for the like five to seven
minute period that i watched
there was okay in that 12 minute period
there was
one guy that caught a small bass but
12 minutes one guy catches a small bat
yeah but during
the while they were waiting the guy
turns to the camera
or you know just addresses the camera
and he's like
you know it's different when you're out
here than when you're watching at home
like it was like and i don't even know
what his point was
was he saying was he more boring to be
here than it is to watch it at home
because at least we're watching an
edited thing
i don't know what his point but if it's
it is different though if it's edited
white i mean it seems like they could
just
i mean with golf you cut to somebody
when they're about to putt
with fishing why can't you just cut to
somebody when they're about to well
i think i think it's all it's a numbers
game in golf
there's approximately 70. there's a lot
of fishermen too hold on no
this is the math your wife was a math
major i know you can follow this
there's like about 70 shots per person
right i don't know how many people there
are fishing versus how many golf
golfers there are golfing in a
tournament but there's 70 times that you
can tune in and see them do something
no one catches 70 fish the guy in the
lead had caught
four bass all day rhett
your wife watches television so i know
you can follow this
you could edit it down to a 22-minute
sitcom
length of bass tournament that's what
i'm saying
what i'm saying is golf can be you can
watch golf for five hours and constantly
see somebody hitting it
you watch bass fishing for an hour and
you watch and i watched 12 minutes which
is one-fifth of an
hour and i saw one fish get taken
there's not enough fishing it's like
they need to you know and just like in
order to make soccer more interesting
just make it a youtube video
they need to make the goal bigger or get
rid of the keeper
and then everybody's going to fall in
love with soccer if you want people to
fall in love with bass fishing
you got to use better bait or there's
got to be bigger fish there's got i
don't know
i mean editing editing but but
even then it's still just people
catching fish
and it's not as entertaining as a as an
instagram
video that i saw recently where there
was a little girl like
a year and a half years old
i don't know how you say that a year and
a half old who
her dad had called a very big bass and
she was hugging it and she was
saying it's okay fish
i love you fish it's okay fish
and then they put the fish back okay so
if you can bring a baby
who can talk to the fish that's the kind
of thing that i would be into
everybody needs to have a baby in their
boat who addresses the fish
before it's thrown back we're gonna read
through
your completions of the sentence am i
weird because i
blank and you might think that we're
going to judge you
and that we're going to say yes you are
weird or no you're not weird well that's
the point isn't it but the real point
is that we're going to celebrate
weirdness you know what well there's
nothing wrong with being weird but we
are gonna tell you if you are
uh i once heard it said
just yourself be if weird as you embrace
it
and that's what this is this is this is
not ultimately judgment this is
celebration of strangeness and i'm a
little biased because
i know i'm weird can i tell you my
criteria for judging these things
yeah um to me
if there's something if you if one of
these things that you do
is to like it brings you comfort or
something like that
um and you can't argue with something
that brings somebody comfort right if
this is like a self-soothing thing
we can say anything we want but to me
i'm gonna i'm gonna
there's two things i'm gonna judge one
is this
something that you would be considered
normal in other words
are you an exception to the majority of
people because you do this
like is this an unusual behavior i think
that's that's one way i'm going to look
at it
and the second thing is like
is should we be concerned
you know what i'm saying like should we
be concerned about you well let's let's
get into it
aubry stamey uh replied to us
she tweeted am i weird because i rub my
feet together to fall asleep
are you a cricket i think they're
rubbing their legs together
in order to mate i mean do they even
have feet crickets
do you think it ends with the ends of
this leg yeah it's just kind of the leg
just kind of like there's an
ankle i think but then on the other side
of the ankle it's just a little bit more
leg i don't i wouldn't call it a foot i
wouldn't call it a foot i'd call it a
short leg after an ankle
it's really no different what's the
difference between a short leg after an
ankle and a foot that goes a different
direction toes
you think you have to have toes to have
a foot yeah
i don't think insects have feet man so
you think so well
what if somebody crickets what if
somebody loses all their toes like if i
google chris
by that rationale if you lose all your
toes in an accident you don't have a
foot anymore man that's just more leg
now
that's not true well i don't want to i
don't why are you gonna go straight to
mamie because i gotta find logic
somewhere all right i just searched
cricketfoot
and a great name for a band the only
thing that came up was like
a close-up of a cleat on someone who's
playing
cricket the australian version of
baseball i wonder how many actions
i think i think i could get into that
before bass fishing uh
watching cricket now i just said that
qriket was australian baseball but
cricket is from uh
it's from where uh well i mean i think
it's a british origin
yeah because it's made its way to it's
very popular in australia it's very
popular in india
it's very popular in places that the i'm
not nothing colonized
i'm scrolling down nothing is related to
the insect
cricket can you do cricket leg hold on
cricket feet in bed
is a related search to cricket foot i'ma
click on that
ah oh we found it we found
it we found what this does anybody else
is asking about
i do i didn't know this was a reddit
though there's a reddit thread called
does anybody
else d-a-e i'm gonna have to follow this
as soon as i hop in bed and lay down
this is
somebody's post uh kristen bryant from
four years ago
and this is answering your question is
this normal we're about to find that out
as soon as i hop in bed and lay down i
have the instant urge to begin rubbing
my feet together most times i don't
realize i'm doing it but then i catch
myself if i separate my feet i'll just
end up rubbing my
foot feet on the bed sheets it's like it
relaxes me i've been doing it for as
long as i can remember
top comment you damn crickets
right which is the same thing that we
said that's the obvious joke
uh someone else commented used to do
this because i have rls
restless leg syndrome which i have you
have resist like central
but interestingly do you do this um i
don't rub my feet together
i move my legs my wife however
does this she rubs her feet together but
you know the other thing she does how do
you know she does it
can you hear it yeah because you can
like see you can kind of see
her legs moving and you can feel it in
the bed but you know the other thing
that she does and this is a little
something shorter than you her feet are
probably at my knees
she also um she rubs my feet
with her feet excuse me she does
and uh she gets upset with me because
i cannot go to sleep if someone else is
touching me
yeah i i do all kinds of touching when
i'm not sleeping
but when i'm done with the touching i'm
ready for the sleeping and they're
mutually exclusive
uh so i mean i'm not saying i'm not a
cuddler but i'm not a cuddle
sleeper but she now that we got a bigger
bed that's the situation
we're in a double bed we'd be we'd have
like 18 points of contact
i just can't fall asleep like that
because i'm super like sleeper but she
will have her foot
on my foot and start rubbing it and i
and my feet are sensitive man i don't
like that i don't like a foot massage
yeah for the longest time when i get a
pedicure i would get a full body massage
sands feet yeah leave the feet off the
table because they spent a lot of time
on the feet and that's time they could
be spent
somewhere better boy i miss massages i
don't get those anymore
um i've been holding back on you here
right so i don't think this is weird
i do this oh you do this yeah and i i
didn't really think about it but i i do
this
and uh i may have mentioned this on the
show
or maybe a good mythical more or maybe
just to you as a friend
but the new thing that i've added to my
i i get in the bed i
my feet kind of rub together a little
bit it's not like my feet i rub my feet
together until i doze off
like lando has this habit from when he
was like
almost as soon as he had hair so i'm
going to say a newborn but like
as soon as lando had hair long enough in
like the back
like the mullet area he would he would
twirl his
finger in his hair and
as long as i can remember he's done it
and he still does it it's kind of like a
way that
he falls asleep and as a as a toddler
he would twist his finger in his hair
and then uh he would put him to bed and
then
he would be crying and we'd go back in
there and his finger would be caught
he would have nodded his finger and not
be able to get it out christy had to use
scissors
and cut his finger off you know to cut
the knot out
um but i'll just do it for like just
like oh i'm in bed i'm finding my spot
my feet rubbed together
a little bit and then i started shifting
my hips
and my lower back would pop and now
every single time right before i go to
sleep
i i'll like i'll shakira my hips you
need the pop now
and then it pops right there and it's
it's and if you don't get a pop you go
to sleep with a sense of
inadequacy yeah so now about this i'm
becoming like a baseball player that's
like got this routine
or a quick qriket player he has to stay
on some you know subject
uh cricket footwork is is its own thing
it has its own wikipedia entry which i'm
not gonna read
um so yeah aubry you know what you're
not weird
uh jesse has spoken
link has spoken and a lot of redditors
have spoken
kiki kanuk said i thought everyone did
this
if not why not it feels amazing my
husband and i both do it
including with each other's feet yeah
see there you go that's what my wife is
trying to do to me
so there you go if you haven't tried it
try it and and put a little shakira into
it
um see look at that all right so this is
this one it's kind of a letdown it
wasn't weird this might surprise you
tom dolls tom dahl's magic
who based on his profile i think he's a
real magician i think he seems like a
magician yeah he has a deck of cards in
his profile picture
he's holding a deck of cards right next
to his cheek
lovingly well because you got to get it
and pick in the picture of the
twitter picture magicians they they have
i don't think he typically holds it next
to his face they have a relationship
with
cards that it is borderline
inappropriate
yeah so tom you are weird because you're
a magician but that's not what you're
asking
uh am i weird because i bite my
fingernails and floss my teeth with them
embarrassed emoji well
i do this well i mean
does it work okay so i do not
i no longer bite my fingernails
but i bit my fingernails consistently
exclusively as a way of trimming my
fingernails up until
three years ago would you consider it a
habit because i considered
i mean i bite my fingernails and it's
it's been a habit that i haven't been
able to break
it was not a nervous habit it was a this
is how i deal with my fingernails
getting too long
honestly it was like ah my fingernails
are too long
we don't we're not an organized
household so it's like finding the nail
clippers it's like they're not always in
the same place and so
i i just was like okay i'll just start
biting them so it wasn't a nervous thing
it was a thing
why did you stop um because
i started i had the you might notice
this if you ever seen
close-ups of my hands but you're like
what the hell is happening with rhett's
fingernails
i've talked about this before but i've
got the uh basically like
psoriasis-based
psoriasis-based psoriasis under my
fingernails right so
does it taste bad it tastes great
but like the fingernail will detach
in some places right and so what i found
is like it's happening right there see
how it's getting white right there oh it
makes it white because there's space
and uh i found that it's much easier to
manage them if i use
a sharp thing and then like file them
down
it seems to help with the problem i
don't know why plus we shouldn't be
you know we've gotten strict about not
putting our hands
in our mouths and in our eyes and stuff
but when i used to do this on a regular
basis
i would take one and then i never even
thought about the fact that i was doing
this and i would not have called it
flossing
but definitely i would see which teeth i
could get it in between
especially the two front ones i put it
in there and i'd start moving it back
and forth just that that was a habit
it was less of a i'm flossing and more
of a habit but it was technically
flossing i was flossing with fingernails
i'm making a gross
out face because it just seems a little
gross it is gross and i am not a
magician
and i've never been a magician and i've
never even thought about being a
magician
but yet i still do this i think they're
unrelated then
okay well i was just seeing trying that
on for size
well i think this is gross i think it's
weird
you know i mean if it were your toenails
it would be even
more gross you know people the whole
cutting and sniffing your toenails i do
not bite my toenails never did
but i could i'm flexible enough but i
mean
there is this urge to smell your own
toenail and i don't know
i do that i'd why because
it's amazing how awful it can smell
sometimes
and i'm just like how what happened what
got caught under there
but it but that there is something
there's a there's like a primal urge
associated with it it's like you know
that why does a dog smell its own [ __ ]
sometimes
what's barbara doing the other day i
asked her she did not respond because
they they learned something well i
learned something about myself when i
smell my
toenail clippings like something is
wrong with my feet
i need to do something about it but how
many times do you need to learn that
i i think that there's no there's the
primal urge
is is different than that it's not a
it's not diagnostic
you're right you're right it's um it's
like eating black licorice honestly for
me
it's it's extremely bad like if there's
something in a room
that smells awful i can't help but smell
it if there's something
in a movie that's really difficult to
watch i do not turn away
if i go by a wreck i look to see if
there's a body with a
sheet over it i'm not okay okay so we're
back to the
the i think it was called
pseudomasochistic
tendency when we were talking about uh
eating spicy
foods yeah so maybe there's something in
there
uh of course i'm not a magician so right
so i would
wouldn't know for sure i i do think that
this
is people do it it's gross but
gross doesn't automatically mean weird i
think
weird is kind of like if something's
gross
it it increases the chances of it being
weird if it's also
strange like you've like or inventive
like i've never heard of this before the
fact that you do this
did this okay whatever
then
i don't know i'm hesitant to say this i
think it's weird i think the
average person when he's seeing the
definitely if they witness this
yeah if someone else sees you do it
maybe that dude's weird
then you become a weird person uh
you're on the you're on the weird
spectrum i also think he has that ace up
his sleeve
in this case okay we've got more of
these to go through but we also
uh want to remind you that we have a
website we've
we've done it we finally did it we got a
website mythical.com
we've had it for quite a while oh that's
right yeah i was just kind of talking
like in this lifetime we've got it
it used to be called ruttenlink.com and
they were like you know what this ain't
this ain't about us
this is about a world that we're all a
part of and
you can buy things yeah right that's
really the reason and identify
with the world that you're that you're
part of we're all in this together
but the only way to really know it is to
wear it and
if you want to get something from
mythical.com
with standard shipping and receive it by
christmas you have to order it no later
than december 10th
i think the coloring book is isn't it
there might be something it's got its
own
pipeline uh but for most everything else
december 10th for domestic standard
shipping
to get it by christmas mythical.com
we got all types of gifts and gift cards
i'm on um the third day in a row
of not taking my allergy pill i've
noticed you've been sneezing
and i sneezed nine times
in a row this morning i'm never that
does not happen to me
that's a lot uh i'm slightly allergic to
there's something floating around i'm
slightly allergic to dogs like when i
got my allergy test a few years ago dogs
and cats
registered on the very very low
but like i ran out of my uh i'm a zyrtec
man
and i ran out and i haven't gotten any
more
and then there was a part of me that was
like maybe i should just see if i can
get off of it
sometimes when you sneeze a bunch it's
like your body needs to do it so there
there is a sense of relief and on
pleasure
you talk about a primal urge there is a
there is pleasure associated with the
sneeze unless it goes sideways
i mean out of the year and you know no
it's
sometimes it can't happen it just
doesn't come out the right way
but i mean nine in did you fully
experience like a bell curve of pleasure
and pain it felt good every time but it
was
annoying to me and my wife how much what
percentage of
what percentage of uh air comes out of
your nose versus your mouth when you
sneeze
uh mostly out my mouth unless
i've made a decision to force it to
force it out of my nose in order to like
get a pat
i call that a power block yeah i'm i'm
really scared of that i'm really scared
of that
yeah it comes off it doesn't accomplish
much because it's almost
all mouth a lot of force if you if you
force like
like 95 percent of that force through
your nose
your eyes i mean you got a you got a
deviated septum yeah you could lose an
eye
it could straighten it out i don't think
it can straighten out bone though
over time there's probably another way
to fix it
anyway i need my allergy bills i'm
struggling nuts
catelyn pemberton
responded to us am i weird because i
can talk with my mouth closed i've known
people who could do this
i do not understand how it works i've
witnessed it i do not think it's weird i
think it
is remarkable well i i've never
witnessed it
i think we should try it okay be my
guest
not even close can you understand what
i'm saying
not even close
you're making a series of humming noises
that's all i hear it's
like i'm hearing somebody through a wall
my lips are still together but i'm
trying to speak normally
you're not saying anything yeah
i can't do it say something i'm saying
my lips are still together don't say
that i said that you say something
different
why are your eyes getting so big your
eyes don't have anything to do with this
i said i'm saying something different
okay
you we you need to if you have not like
seen a youtube video this before
like what we're talking about is someone
who can
talk articulately
as if there's another mouth inside their
mouth
you need to watch a you should watch a
video of this real quick uh
just so i mean we can cut this out so we
won't get it flagged or whatever but you
you just need to
you so you will understand what this is
okay now stop that stop that oh i can do
that
you sound like someone who is making
preliminary sounds but not completing
them with the tongue
and the lips she sounds like someone who
has tongue and lips
inside her mouth like an alien mouth how
is that possible yeah she's got a
talking
talker trapped in there no physically
what is happening do you understand it
because this is the real magician well
when i
when i searched um talk with your mouth
closed the first thing that comes up is
a wiki how
how to speak with your mouth closed
you'll need to make sure your lips are
parted ever so slightly
without parting your lips just a little
bit you won't be able to get any sound
out of your mouth
practice parting oh so it's cheating
wikihow's never reliable though
that's not what she was doing she looks
like her mouth is completely closed
yeah this is not wikihow is off off off
the rails
touch your teeth together make sure your
tongue can move
look at yourself in the mirror what you
should not be able to see your tongue
you should be able to see your teeth
your mouth's not closed
yeah this is crap man i don't just get
it breathe normally
i think it's just magic so we're back to
that
i think that that is it's not weird man
i think you're a freak
caitlyn i think you are a freak and
there you know there's others
you can find them and then you keep it
to yourself you can speak to each other
that way
but it's impressive what i'm saying is
it's a good part it's that's a that's a
legit party trick
that's not like flossing with your with
your fingernails
yeah this is something you do by
yourself this is something you do in the
company of other people and they're
impressed and they ask
okay questions about it so you're a
freak but no you're not weird
yeah you're talented talented exactly
uh hi responded
that's an unpronounceable vixen trash
iv said
i can't watch any show am i weird
because i can't watch
any show unless i know what happens
first like
if i'm watching an episode of some show
i have to google
what happens before i finish it or i get
nervous
and then i can't watch the rest of the
episode because i'm too
tense about what might happen even
jeopardy
you know those jeopardy episodes wow
i'll tell you
the jeopardy always ends in one of three
ways
one of the three people wins can you
imagine having to
google the episode of jeopardy you're
watching you get that information
i mean it's probably that's probably
even wiki i mean like the tivo or
whatever would say the episode number
and then i gotta know who's gonna win
this one but then somebody responded
jennifer sanford responded to this tweet
and said
omg i thought i was the only one who did
this
my brother definitely thinks i'm weird
when i do this okay
here can i just give you my knee-jerk
reaction today sure
uh i'm not a therapist uh i have been in
therapy for
some time uh not the same thing
not the same thing that's why i'm saying
it as a disclaimer
um this has got this is something about
control
i mean there's something about i don't
know it's related to
the unknown unknown is too much too much
to take uh
but it feels like this is an example
of what do you call it when you is it
called exposure therapy like
when you're afraid of something and then
you expose yourself to it in order to
overcome it
this feels again i'm not i'm not you i
don't understand
this personally spider down your pants
uh and i'm in this
that's double meaning exposure therapy
and then if this is a real
like if this is like a super anxious
thing and i'm not giving you medical or
psychological
advice but it feels like at least with
an episode of
jeopardy might be a good place to start
like i think
i think you can make it through an
episode of jeopardy well who are you
and let the i'm just saying if you can't
i think you might need to talk
it out with somebody it's really what
yeah i agree with that i think that's
what i'm getting at yeah uh
this is not we this isn't i wouldn't say
weird though because i feel like that
makes it
you know judgey you don't want to judge
somebody weird dealing with something
that's uh
you know that might require but i'm but
i'm sympathetic
i'm sympathetic to this and i feel like
it's something that you that
you shouldn't have to go through life
with this is a sign of a
of uh of a deeper issue which
maybe you're cool with it uh or maybe
you want to look into it
i would have to think that this tendency
has to play itself out into just life in
general right
like so this would be like i mean every
single day is a jeopardy episode right
every single day is a day in which you
don't know what trebek's going to say
you don't know who's going to win
you don't know what's going to happen in
your life but you don't have the ability
to go
and see but you know when see if this
person
who tweeted and i can't pronounce their
username is listening now
and they didn't realize what you're
saying boy you've just made it a whole
lot worse
but here's the thing i think i can
actually in a weird way relate to this
it's just something that's coming to me
so you know we've talked in the past
about how uh
i actually and much more there's a lot
more going on
emotionally than i ever realized until i
started going to therapy
and one of the ways that my emotions
come out is in things that feel like
there's not any stakes and i'm not
personally invested in
i.e television and movies and
commercials right i'll cry in all those
scenarios yeah
because it's not personal so i think
that this particular person hi
might be like i can't deal with the fact
that i've got uncertainty in my life
but when i expose myself to an episode
of jeopardy or
some some show i know that the
the outcome does exist i can google the
outcome
and i can gain a little bit of security
and control in this
thing in a way that i can't do in life
and that brings me a sense of
security right yeah and so that's my
theory as to what's going on so
but if yeah if you can get to a place
where you can embrace
an episode of jeopardy not knowing which
of the three people is going to win
i guess sometimes there's a tie is that
possible can there be a tie
rolls over to the next episode no i
don't think so okay so somebody's gonna
win
if you can just let that ride then maybe
you can get a little bit more bet a
little bit better at dealing with just
a typical day i don't know i'm not a
professional
you take it or leave it take it with a
grain of salt since november 2014
ties for first place following final
jeopardy are broken with a tiebreaker
clue
resulting in only a single champion
being named keeping their winnings and
returning to competing in the next show
if no contestant finishes final jeopardy
with a positive total there is no winner
so
there's a fourth option there could be
three losers how many times has that
happened
jeopardy just got more interesting and
that was only since 2014.
i mean how could three people go into
final jeopardy and make wagers
that put them in the negative that means
somebody's not playing right
somebody's making a bad decision uh
on march 2nd 2018
jeopardy history was made when two
contestants competed during the final
tournament of thursday's episode
while all three of the show's
competitors wrote in the wrong wrote and
wrong submissions for the channel
islands prompt
laura and sarah found themselves in a
tie which led to the first
ever final jeopardy tie breaker
first ever a minute how did they do the
tiebreaker it's just another question
with another wager with a tiebreaker
clue oh
are broken with a tiebreaker clue so is
it a clue about the same question
you get a hint like gm that seems a
little lame
i mean we would never do that uh
yeah i think there's something just to
get back to the question
you know with all the googling i'm doing
today i did some preemptive googling
when i picked this question
and uh i i could not find something to
google that would bring up people who
related to this
unlike the rubbing your feet together
you know it's
i i i can't i can't i can't google
are you do you have to look up the
results of of
of a show before you can watch it i know
people
who read and i and i've done this i
googled that but nothing came out as a
kid i would would look at like
the last sentence of a book but it was
for like a different reason it wasn't to
know how it was going to end necessarily
it was just because it was there to be
read i don't know
there's an anxiety yeah yeah yeah and it
i i don't do that by the way i don't do
it anymore
there's something going on here so we've
successfully backed away
uh it's up to you what you want to do
with it we're not even going to say if
it's weird or not
i don't think it's weird i think it's
not weird
emily little tweeted at us am i weird
because i won't watch a movie more than
once
okay more of a general topic
i i feel like i'm one of these people
um i know that i'm a weird person so
by the associative principle emily you
are also weird
no i uh
i had to work up a lot of energy to
re-watch the big lebowski which
as we established is um both of our
favorite
comedies of all time it had been so long
since i watched it when we're talking to
our college friends they always
reference it so much i'm like you know
what
i'd like to see this after like over a
decade of not watching it
but i i rarely
and i always thought it was like movie
lovers
and and people who are like really like
students of film
they should watch the same movie again
and again i mean you don't gain
you gain insight through that but like a
normal viewer
uh i just haven't related to it i feel
like there's so much stuff out there i
it's hard for me to justify to myself
the investment of time to re-watch
something
that i know already know what's going to
happen kind of to the last point yeah i
it's not as fun i don't i mean this
here's here's what i find interesting
about this situation between me and you
is that
you know i don't watch the same movie
twice i don't do the same thing twice i
don't eat the same meal twice
i don't go to the same restaurant twice
i don't go to the same city on vacation
twice but interestingly you do that
right like
yeah you guys will go to the same place
uh on vacation
like you find something that you like
but it's not the same
it feels watching the show is a
different experience
it's it's it's not it's a compromised
experience like
the surprise of what's going to happen
because i'm also you know i'm the
stickler of sticklers when it comes to
to trailers i mean spoilers
well trailers like i don't watch
trailers of movies i'm going to watch
and i want to read anything about him if
i know i'm going to watch it because it
just takes away from the experience
like it annoys me anything built any
marketing built around
a work of art is
to me a spoiler of some aspect of that
experience that the artist wanted to
create
yeah and it's annoying to me and i'm not
i'm not spoiler sensitive like it
doesn't it doesn't ruin it for me
but it's to me the principle that i
apply to media is the same thing i apply
to a restaurant it's like
back when we used to go to restaurants
on a regular basis in los angeles like
jesse and i would
very rarely go to the same place twice
because i'm just like i'm in one of the
biggest cities in the world
there's always a new place and we both
think like that and so we're just like
and it doesn't always result in a better
meal
no often it's just like but i think when
i look at
movies or tv shows or whatever
i just think there's and i don't just
like you were saying it's like if you're
gonna take the time
to devote two hours of your evening to
something it's like why devote
to the same thing however the other
night at your house
yeah we watched we re-watched a movie
and the funny thing is
is when that was your idea by the way
when you all said that we were going to
watch
us uh the movie i
might i wasn't excited about it as much
as i absolutely loved that movie i've
only seen it once
i uh i wasn't excited about it but i had
an incredible time re-watching that
movie so it made me actually think twice
about re-watching movies well that movie
is
specifically constructed that bless you
is there going to be eight more because
i just want i don't know there might be
one more at least
jordan pill constructed this movie in
such a way that once you
once you've watched it you have a you
know what to watch for
you have a different experience watching
it the second time i i believe a movie
with a reveal
is a completely different experience
i think that's that's something that hit
me it's like oh man like if you watch a
movie with a significant reveal of some
kind or a twist
you should watch it again now do you
think that saying that a movie has a
twist is a spoiler
like does that violate your response
absolutely yes with spoiler alert
a little late hmm yeah
that doesn't attract with me but i'm
sorry if if uh
if i ruined us for you that that is
that is a huge sport to say that there's
a twist at the end
or a reveal but how many movies
so many movies have reveals any almost
all movies have revealed except just
like straight
drama like with
right i'm gonna i'm gonna make us a a
spoiler alert for
mandalorian season two okay so only you
can skip forward i have no
i haven't watched 15 seconds uh you're
not going to ruin it for me i watched it
tonight
that's why i'm telling you but i
wouldn't want you to tell me this okay
but on
like the twitter moments the day after
the mandalorian
episode came out it said mandalorian
season two premieres
with an amazing character reveal well of
course they're going to tell you who the
mandalorian is i mean
you don't go a second season not knowing
who the the actor who plays him which by
the way i saw an article about the
actor who plays him before i ever
watched the season before i got started
okay well i don't want to you know
in an effort well i i hate to spoil more
but i just can't help myself to just
tell you that you're wrong
okay but he will be revealed well that's
not what we're talking about
my point is they said that there's an
amazing character reveal
you you you misinterpreted it and i knew
the answer but
i think that again i i would not have
wanted to know
that and i was glad i'd already watched
the episode that's why i make sure that
i watch the episode right when it comes
to that like baby yoda has like a spider
body or something like that
all right let i told him to skip forward
15 seconds we're not talking about it
anymore
uh so we don't think that emily is weird
because she won't watch a movie more
than once but
there are i think there's some
exceptions yeah how about
uh schnozamanian
am i weird because i ask people to
repeat what they have said to me even
though i heard them loud and clear
i just do and it's completely out of my
control it's completely out of your
control
uh we knew somebody like this
schnazamanian
i'm just gonna tell you that i i feel a
little anger welling up inside
when i when i read your confession i
mean it's
well and the person that i'm thinking
about right now who we both know from
our past who we
will remain nameless and i don't know
who you're talking about can you just
just
huh huh
i almost remember but i don't huh like i
know that there was this person in our
lives
but i can't remember huh
oh are you talking about the
back from our high school days oh i
thought you were he was older than us
he was in college when we were in high
school huh huh
just tell me and we'll have to bleep it
out uh
say it oh yeah
he did do that didn't he huh
huh wow how long no matter what you said
no matter at what point you were in and
what you were saying huh
he said huh and i guarantee you he's
serious he was hearing you the whole
time huh
so i don't know i don't know if this is
what you do
if this is what you do you need to stop
it immediately yeah that's not
it's and you say you can't it's out of
my control
i think that's a lie that you're telling
yourself
there's what what causes that do you
remember it
and it doesn't have i do now yeah and it
maybe schnoz doesn't
like constantly give the huh but even if
it's like what was that
when you're done what'd you say
how could that even happen oh i now ed i
don't know
when my kids when my kids were younger
like
i i seem to recall having an experience
a parenting experience so i'm like that
they'll
there was a phase that i think lillian
lincoln went through where they would be
like what
and i i remember deciding to start to
say you heard me
hold on you heard me what what what did
you hear
and by the way when we forced them i
forced them to say because it was in
their brains yeah i did
i did hear it it's like they have to
replay it and then well the same thing
happens
it does go both ways i mean how many
times have my kids ask me something and
i've just
i never thought i would be this but it
turns out this is just what being a dad
is
it's here your kid's asking you you're
asleep in a recliner with a remote on
your
crotch i'm not asleep i'm just doing
what dad wants to do and when children
ask questions of me
i do not it's i'm impervious
and so they're like dad you heard me and
then i do the same thing and i'm like
oh i did hear you yeah it is in my brain
but i had not
reckoned with it until now so this goes
both ways this is not a good practice
for anyone
i mean you you've got to just take a
beat and say
i'm about to ask them to repeat
themselves but did i just
did i actually hear it yes i did i'm
hearing it again now in my memory
i'm responding to it i'm not burdening
somebody to say something again and i
don't think this is weird i think this
is based on my experience
this is just annoying uh you know to be
completely
harsh and honest about it uh again we i
i'm just going off of my personal
experience with it
from this one person well i think you
know that might be our next
am i annoying because i blank okay yeah
there's we can if we can keep going down
this rabbit hole
uh lara la ror
said am i weird because i eat raw pasta
as a snack
the crunch when you bite it is so
satisfying like a hard candy but it's
savory
i i i've i've eaten a
i taught strand of spaghetti before
taught and i felt like i felt like it
was going to break my tooth
was it us and it was spaghetti linguine
i didn't try i only tried spaghetti
and i mean there's there's a bit of
danger involved it's like kind of like
chewing glass
and the taste is very subtle i think it
might be overstating the danger
but this just seems like a preference i
mean
they're okay i remember one time i went
over to uh
peter dinklage's house and you know i it
sounds like a name drop but that was
just my neighbor growing up
uh a different one and
he went into the fridge and grabbed
a hot dog cold which he called a raw hot
dog
and this is before i really understood
that hot dogs were pre-cooked yeah and
he just ate it out of the fridge
and i was like he's weird he eats raw
hot dogs
but you know me one night in my house
curiosity got the best and i ate a raw
hot dog
and i was like i kind of get this i sort
of get this
but it might make me weird i don't think
i would enjoy it now but as a kid
i i would do that i i think eating
uncooked pasta is more strange
um because it's it's so good
i mean i i like a good crunch but the
crunch is so intense
there are other tastes that are crunchy
and savory like crackers
chips but nothing is as crunchy
as uncooked pasta there are things made
from wheat that are crunchy like a wheat
thin
like a wheat thin feels like you're
getting close to just eating straight
pasta but
it's been made into a form so i think
you should maybe just switch to wheat
i disagree the more i think about it i
can't think of anything that you could
eat
that is crunchier than uncooked pasta
i mean it's it's almost like glass
you think i'm exaggerating but have you
done it have you ever eaten
raw pasta i'm sure i have at one point
well not raw but
uncooked but it's also there's no flavor
to it like it hasn't been salted
i it's as hard as it as a fingernail
that floss with it that's the truth man
i mean it's brittle but it's but it's as
hard
if that makes sense i think this is uh
is this weird i i get the crunch like if
you need an extreme crunch i can't think
of anything that's going to rival that
laura
so i'm going to say that it's not weird
i'm going to say you're you've got a
crunch fetish
and i think you should explore other
things
i think that this is weird but it's okay
you know what i'm saying like yeah
that's why i use the word fetish i think
that's what fetish means to me
weird but okay no judgment okay well if
if
if if i was inventing a character for a
story
uh and you know there's the principle
that blake snyder talks about you know
olympian and eyepatch you give every
character in a narrative
something notable makes them a little
bit different okay i think that
this character eats raw pasta
yeah that's a that's a good character
it's like that's fun to me
it's a little quirky and i would say i
would get into we i think it's weird but
it's good weird
that's my conclusion margaret all right
so we disagree stivers or stivers
am i weird because i like to mix baked
beans with cottage cheese
now this is a mixture of worlds on a
on a recent carpool vlog we do videos
for the mythical society where we like
we we we're riding in the car it's like
a 20-minute video where we're just
shooting the breeze sometimes we do
answer questions but
i don't know how it came up but i shared
with you
that my i'm obsessed my favorite type of
cheese
right now is cottage cheese i love it i
love to put a bowl of
that that sloppy oozy white
crumb like what are those like nodules
of
cottage cheese in a bowl throw some
walnuts on it i'm surprised that you
like it because you kind of get grossed
out by cheese
sometimes and i think cottage cheese
it's well i also like it it's like
it's like it feels like the grossest
kind of cheese besides maybe blue cheese
it's like a
cereal it doesn't it tastes bland it's
in a bowl i eat it with a spoon
what is it called cottage a cereal
experience but
have you ever had a protein have you
ever had it in a cottage uh
i i fancy my house in cottage why is it
a cottage
is it made in cottages or is it made
from a region that has a lot of cottages
all right man i mean i'm i've been
pretty good at googling
why is it called
cottage cheese
it is made from different types of milk
with different fat levels the term
cottage cheese is believed to have
originated because the cheese was
generally made in cottages from milk
left over
after making butter the cheese is creamy
lumpy and sold in pots cottage
this is this is from cheese.com by the
way
i think okay the way i'm interpreting
what you just read
is that more traditional cheese like say
a cheddar
is a is a result of a process an
intentional process like by a cheese
maker
but cottage cheese is like cheese that
happened at somebody's house
in a more this is leftover kind of
accidental way almost
cottage cheese is thought to be the
first cheese made in america
yeah this is making lots of sense for
centuries farmers in europe made fresh
farmhouse cheeses with naturally soured
milk after separating the curds from the
whey
immigrants to america brought the
tradition of fresh cheese making with
them and by the mid-1800s the term
cottage cheese
entered the american vocabulary cottage
cheese is so both plain
it's the original cheese cottage cheese
is the original american cheese
yeah just like me
sorry i'm sniffing man you should i
think we have zyrtec
here at the office i'm gonna get some in
a second
i didn't think the withdrawal would be
this bad i read a whole reddit thread
about zyrtec withdrawal some people have
crazy itching happen
that's not happening to me i just got
the sniffies what are your toenails
smell like
that's going to be an interesting smell
right now i was also told that
eating cottage cheese before you go to
bed is good is it drinks
is is good for um no the it's a good
way to get the type of protein casein
that your body needs when you're
sleeping casein
slow release protein uh i mean the
theory is
because unlike whey protein which is an
immediate release which you should do
like right after you work out because
your muscles are hungry for it
you take casein before you go to sleep
which and you can buy casein just as a
powder sometimes i'll drink like a thing
just get it in the cup maybe i should
just do the cottage cheese and also
dairy before you go to sleep
my experience is causing you to have
crazy dreams
i don't know what they're going to do
for one because i'm starting to eat
cottage cheese
but the question was mixing beans with
cottage cheese that is weird
that yeah that's weird i've never heard
of that beans and cheese
bean and cheese burrito that's a thing
but
beans and cottage cheese is not warm
cottage cheese is cold
i mean if i search beans and cottage
cheese
what compliments cottage cheese people
ask
sliced bananas crushed pineapple berries
melon chunks fresh peaches everything's
about
sweet everything that complements
cottage cheese is sweet yeah nothing
i mean food.com has the beans
cheese recipe i think if it becomes more
like a cream cheese thing
then maybe that could be good this is
this is the mix this is the melding of
our worlds right
i bring the cottage you bring the beans
let's get together and make a scene
do you heat the cottage cheese up i mean
it's a this is a food.com recipe
how many reviews is it by jeff hammer i
think this is user generated
did anybody comment on this you know
only
jeff commented up nope down here
don k
he said don't cook the beans okay
i don't know there's not many people
it's not food.com is not a cauldron of
conversation
apparently so yeah i i'm going to say
this is
this is this is weird even and i'm going
to go there as well
i think this is weird i mean you don't
want to try it
oh i'll try it i gotta sneeze again
okay you probably just deposited
something on your right shoulder
people are gonna think you've got the
cove i don't man it's allergies it's it
just happens
every time i run out of my allergy bills
all right laura you're weird
margaret you're weird let's get to mary
quite contrary am i weird
because i hit myself when i see a crow
because i think it gets rid of when i
say blad
because i think it gets rid of bad luck
so if i see
four i hit myself four times if i say 20
yep 20 taps on my chest okay she's
she moved from hitting to tapping which
that's good
i'm aware it is irrational and i try not
to but i can't help it
hashtag your biscuits so this is
obviously a compulsive
superstition right uh yeah
so yeah i don't think you i don't think
it makes you weird
i mean knocking on wood but freaking
i mean like to me this is kind of like
punch bug
like if you're in the car and you're
like you know
when me and my mom used to you should
ride in the car together if we saw a
punch bug you'd say that
you saw a volkswagen bug on the road and
whatever color it was
punch bug blue if you were the first
person and you'd punch him punch him on
the shoulder
so i would punch my mom on the shoulder
but she would also punch me on the
shoulder it was kind of like a love lick
to me that's more green that's more
about bonding that's a social
experiment that's a social body that
works but then this is something this is
a compulsive behavior
is it not yeah it's just a it's a
i can't so it doesn't make you weird it
makes you actually pretty i mean this is
very common this is very normal
everyone has compulsive behavior some
are more pronounced than others
some cross into as you have described
irrationality and superstition
uh like when i would feed my dog tucker
i would always feed him
and now i pat him on the head five times
i would count
five times pat pat pat pat pat
and then i would feel like okay my job
is complete
i've patted him four times he's gotten
what he needs five times
five times uh i don't think this
i don't think this is weird and i and i
don't and i don't think that it is
necessarily
bad unless it becomes
if it if it's in other areas of your
life i mean my wife
you know um struggles with ocd
not she doesn't have this particular
type right
but it's not it's very difficult to like
you don't like really get rid of it like
you are always someone who struggles
with it and i'm not saying that this
isn't necessarily what it is
but like there's a number of behaviors
like tapping your dog four times or
tapping your chest when you see a crow
that
i feel like there's a little bit of
self-soothing in this it's not
necessarily
some debilitating thing you know it just
depends but
you could probably you probably could
help it if you really wanted to but i
don't necessarily know that it's like
this is like a
something you have to address in order
to move on with it but i but the belief
of thinking that it gets rid of bad luck
it's just incorrect yeah
but make you weird it seems like it's
you know from the outside looking in
without knowing anything and not passing
judgment but just saying uh you know
isn't this an unnecessary constraint on
your life
to to have to to to know that it
this isn't true but then it's like now
you're tapping yourself and
you don't you know you don't feel
soothed is it something that you want to
change perhaps i mean what about like a
it's your call not hours what i mean
what about like a
a baseball player you know they're
notoriously superstitious he wears a
certain pair of stuff you talk about
cricket right
yeah qriket player who wears the same
pair of underwear
until he loses or something like that um
i guess i mean if this isn't hurting
anybody yeah it's fun and it gives you
confidence
you know i got that i got my lucky pair
of tiger underwear or like our lucky
shirts
like i i don't i haven't worn them in a
long time our lucky shirts that we wear
for
the gmm countdown episodes which i mean
of course we don't believe that there's
luck in them we're doing a bit
but i mean if we did believe it it
wouldn't be
weird it would just be superstitious
it's fun it's like i mean
but lucky underwear or something like
that gives you confidence there's a
psychological
thing that like then you can
you can hit the cricket ball or puck or
whatever it is
uh you know you can bat better
but like thinking believing something
that isn't true
isn't necessarily bad i guess is what
i'm saying right like
the and again if it makes you feel
better well but it can
it doesn't hurt anybody it can also uh
you know he talks about this in the book
sapiens
like that's actually one of the things
that makes humans
humans and the ability to cooperate with
each other is the fact that we can
believe a fiction
that like bonds us together we can
believe things that are not true
about ourselves or about other people
and it can be advantageous
so i'm not saying that that's
necessarily what's happening with a
superstition but
i'm just saying that i don't think it's
bad necessarily to believe something
that's not true
if it helps you or helps a group of
people
as long as it's not hurting somebody
because our grasp of what is actually
true is
actually it's not as keen as we all
think it is yeah because
we could find out one day that you know
tapping yourself with crows show up is
really awesome
that it really does counteract the bad
luck that is real that all crows carry
they are smart and they're a lot bigger
than you think what if you get right up
on a crow
they're big what about peck you they
could peck your eye out what if
easily this person goes and watch the
watches the black crows in concert
and they tap along with the beat
hey little thing let me let
oh yeah that too
just yourself be if weird as you
this celebration is now concluded uh
yeah listen i mean we made some
judgments but we told you that's what we
were going to do spoiler alert
uh and you know i think we'll do this
again uh
shall i make a wreck you sure okay i
made this wreck to you i'm going to make
it to you
you know if it's good enough for my
friend it's good enough for you um
you got to have apple you got to have
the apple tv
plus subscription to watch this so if
you have that
definitely check it out um the beastie
boys story
beastie boy story uh there was a book
that was written by
uh adam horowitz and
mike d uh adam yolk he you know he
passed away
uh and the beastie boys were technically
no more but they they wrote this memoir
which is like a super fun book i've
well i actually didn't read the book i
would watch the documentary first and i
loved the documentary so much now i'm
going back and listening to the book on
on uh the audiobook because it's uh
it's really entertaining the way it's
done there's a whole lot more stories
and they read it
they read the book yeah they do and they
have a lot of guest
stars come in and read parts of the book
too lots of people fans of the beastie
boys and the thing that
you know i encourage you to watch uh
it you know it's like it's it's like an
hour and a half it's it's they call it a
live documentary it's a stage show i
mean
if you saw the tour mythicality which
was the stage show
version of the book of mythicality what
they did was very similar you know
they definitely stole our idea it was
the two it was the two of them on stage
with a screen behind them and they would
just cut to like
visuals to support their stories and
they just told their story and it was uh
you know it's scripted and it's a little
stilted at times and they like
use a prompter it actually made me feel
good that like hey
they did something very similar to us
and it's
it they tell the story their friendship
friendship is such a strong
theme so even if you're if you're not a
fan of their music
uh i i would say the first half is you
know they go
chronological it's about you know how
the band started
and it's this it's a crazy story um
but it's really the second half of the
documentary wouldn't you agree
it like really starts to sing like once
they achieved their initial fame
and then i just related to it so much
from a
from a creative standpoint like working
closely
with a lifelong friend of mine and
having to
have it to pivot from from early
successes to find
later successes in their career and just
the
it was very inspiring to me because
i related to so much of it yeah i
thought it was great i mean i
i didn't know i knew so little about
them and
the thing we talked about is we were
trying to figure out why we weren't more
of a fan all along the way yeah like
especially like in the 90s when we were
in high school because we were like
listening to 311 and
i mean 311 is no beastie boys
you know what i'm saying it's in it it's
just interesting that that's what we
gravitated towards but
fascinating story just the way things
worked
back in the day in the music industry
and the way things kind of came up with
look at the new genre being invented
so i think i mean i enjoyed all of it i
thought the beginning was awesome too
because
it's just fascinating to see how all
that came together back
in the mtv days and the way it worked
so foreign the thing that i really
appreciated was
the they processed their entire
experience
through a lens of like a maturity that
they
grew into over time you know that they
said
it's not that we became adults as much
as we kind of just gained some maturity
you know a lot of ways
that i don't think in in a way that i
relate to
in a lot of ways i don't feel like an
adult but i feel like i have this
i can look back on our career with like
this level of maturity
and you know we we haven't pivoted
as much as they did you know from this
their first album and like the the
becoming this like
the becoming the trope that they were
making fun of
while on tour like this fight for your
right to party guys
um and then coming to grips with how
that wasn't who they truly were
i just really enjoyed how they processed
it and and
and presented it with like this
retrospective wisdom that that i didn't
know
i didn't know it was there it's like you
know that adam yak uh
you know he he became this uh
crusader for for tibet and
uh you know he he he's a fascinating guy
and
you get to know him through the lens of
his of of
of his of his friends talking about it
which i thought was really cool too yeah
uh so it was a great tribute to him it's
very moving
um if you like the tour mythicality i
think
you know and if you i could see i can
see how mythical beasts
process us i kind of put myself in their
shoes
in it because you put less pressure on
it and being a fan of the beastie boys
as performers in that moment because
you're kind of taking in their story
yeah and i i started to i really
understood each of them
as an as an individual and began to
understand their personalities and i
felt like i got to know them and
appreciate who they were
and then in going back and listening to
those albums that we should have been
into
you're right before i had this
appreciation for
the albums because i had an appreciation
for who they were as people
and the journeys that they had been on
and i
i feel good that i've that we've given
that
we've given that to mythical beasts you
know we brought them
they understand our journey they know us
as people
they know our quirks they know our
differences they know
they know what what makes us work
together and they're pulling for us
in the way that i was pulling for them
and their story
so when when it seemed like they broke
up without even talking about it
uh that was a that was a great point
spoiler alert
to see what happened from from that
in that moment you know uh and how
they're just
they were they're just real people yeah
and uh
they put it all out there so
the beastie boys story beastie boys
story
recommended now what
well we just say hashtag your biscuits
to continue the conversation
on the interwebs to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best